il faut rendre le métier plus attrayant
alors peut-être que le faire passer en
catégorie belle rendra plus attrayant
mais c'est un énorme problème c'est un
énorme problème de même que le métier
est tellement dur qu'il y a un
absentéisme et un turnover effrayant
nous partout on visite la nuit il y a
personne si un incendie je ne sais pas
j'ose pas penser ce qui va se passer
mais on traverse même de jour des
coursives sans personne sans surveillant
et moi d'entendre à Bois-d'Arcy c'est un
souvenir qui m'est resté vous savez ce
que c'est passé le drapeau
c'est mettre ces petits des petits
feuillets comme ça avec son numéro de
cellule il passait à travers la porte et
l'agiter ça fait ça fait ce petit bruit
et quand les détenus entendent un bruit
de pas dans la coursive tout s'y passe
les drapeaux parce qu'il y a pas de
boutons d'appel dans certaines prisons
qui peut et vous passez être ces
froufrous c'est vite c'est des herbes
ils se disent tiens ça doit être le
surveillant donc on passe vite notre
drapeau pour montrer que ça va pas il
faut améliorer les choses et le métier
de surveillant
il est très dur mais c'est vrai que là
il est c'est pas normal ce qui se passe
et c'est pas normal la façon dont le
recrutement mais pas normal déjà
n'arrive que 26% au concours de
surveillance ce qui a évidemment si on
réussit postier avant ben on choisit
postier avant de surveillant je crois
que c'est le dernier métier qui est
choisi quant aux adjointes surveillants
nous on émet les plus grosses craintes
parce que si des vrais surveillants sont
recrutés à 2 sur 20 je sais pas comment
on recrutera les adjoints comment ils
seront recrutés
[Musique]
voilà oui nous on émet des grosses
inquiétudes là dessus sur ce corps
d'adjoint
pardon
c'est pas moi qui donne la parole
tout simplement madame le contrôleur
général en ce qui concerne les
directeurs d'établissement de plus en
plus ce sont des gens extrêmement
humains qui passent des concours très
très
intéressants et en faculté on leur
propose très souvent en plein d'autres
choix et celui qui prend ce celui qui
passe ce concours je pense qu'il a une
fibre particulière et il faut les
encourager il n'y a pas que les les
surveillants il y a aussi les dirigeants
c'est ce que je me permettais de de
madame merci beaucoup madame la
sénatrice parce que c'est ce qu'on pense
également d'ailleurs j'ai eu l'occasion
de dire récemment sur les fiches de
poste
de recrutement des directeurs de prison
il n'y a pas marqué que je sache
cherchant Superman pour gérer prison
ingérable parce que franchement il faut
être sur permanent pour diriger les
prisons au superwoman les prisons qu'on
visite et nous on a énormément de
rapport avec les directeurs et les
directrices de prison je peux vous le
dire on parle beaucoup avec eux mais là
je parlais des surveillants parce que
c'est eux qui sont dans les coursives au
contact le plus des détenus et que ils
sont franchement désespérés telles
leçons également les directions des
prisons
qui par parenthèse
ne voit pas souvent de magistrats passés
visiter la détention que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de dire au magistrat et ce
qui n'est pas normal parce que quand on
est garant des libertés et qu'on envoie
des gens derrière les barreaux la
moindre des choses peut-être c'est
d'aller voir où on envoie les gens